let's start today with the latest on the
train derailment in East Palestine Ohio
there's a bunch of different stories
here there's of course the regulatory
story there's the story of what caused
this definitively there's the Pete boot
Edge Story which is building even among
some on the left and saying okay even if
it's not Pete boot Edge's fault
why did he not react or act quickly
after it happened which we will talk
about separately but in the immediate
there's the story about what is going on
with chemicals and risks to People's
Health now I want to start and preface
this by saying this is not a conspiracy
Theory show
we debunk conspiracy theories and when
we talk about what's really going on
with the chemicals in East Palestine
Ohio
we are not even needing to take the
position that there's a conspiracy of
some kind here we just know that there
is a history of wrongly assessing health
risks to people from chemical elements
of different kinds and of being slow to
tell people of that being the case so
when we look at this article from The
New York Times which says many in East
Palestine skeptical of official tests
seek out their own it is not a
conspiracy theory to say
the government whether it's federal or
state
hasn't always been right or honest
initially about these things and so we
want more information the New York Times
says the moves reflect residents
deep-seated mistrust of government
screenings of toxic chemicals and fears
of long-term effects from the train
derailment so this is a crazy situation
that's taking place this is Ohio and
people you can check out the article
people who were not satisfied with what
they were being told about toxic
chemicals have been paying independent
contractors to evaluate what is going on
trying to find tests of their own and
you can read the details and you can
read the names of the different
chemicals and you can read the
statements from Norfolk Southern as well
as the state government but there is a
very long history of this so yes one
part of it is wow people are paying
people are so desperate
to know is what's in the air in the
water are are these things harmful to my
health to my family's health people are
so desperate and they are distrustful of
the government to such degree that
they're going into their own pocket an
area that is not a rich area by any
means and saying we're going to try to
figure out how we can pay to get real
answers here
this is reasonable this is not a
conspiracy when you look back I mean
listen you don't have to think back very
far look at the Flint Water Crisis
that's under a decade ago the city of
Flint Michigan we've talked about this
so many times changed its water source
from uh I believe it was from Lake Huron
Huron I don't even know how you say it
Lake Huron to the Flint River and it was
going to be at the end of the day a
money-saving thing and the river water
was corrosive it caused lead to Leach
from old pipes it contaminated drinking
water
and the latest I saw months ago is that
the people of Flint are still on bottled
water and it took years to resolve it
there were denials there were all sorts
of claims made that everything's fine
and everything was not fine and people
ultimately were indicted
um and then there's so many other cases
in the 1970s there was the Love Canal
Love Canal is a neighborhood of Niagara
Falls New York remember you've got
Canadian Niagara Falls and American
Niagara Falls and residents of Love
Canal discovered that their homes and
properties were built on a toxic waste
dump massive dumps not a satirical term
in this case and those chemicals in the
dump were linked to health problems
birth defects cancer Etc the risk was
initially downplayed by governments and
it took years to eventually evacuate
residents there's all these other
examples we've saw it with agent orange
we saw it with tobacco we see it saw it
with Three Mile Island so it is not a
conspiracy theory to say there is a
record of when these sorts of things
happen governments either out of
ignorance or out of wanting to keep
people calm for lack of a better term
um giving information that is wrong and
whether it's deliberate or not doesn't
really matter when you're talking about
the health of your family so that's
where we are right now
um Joe Biden making a last minute trip
to Ukraine but the uh complaints are the
Biden Administration isn't sending
enough people to Ohio a failed former
president Donald Trump now says that he
will go to Ohio to the site of the
derailment on Wednesday I don't know the
details of that but if it's possible and
if there is a public-facing event
um we will try to cover that and if Joe
Biden goes we will try to cover that as
well but that's where we are and it is
unclear at this point how the residents
of Ohio right now get definitive answers
about Water and Air and soil and and
those sorts of elements eventually I'm
sure we will get the full story
including from official entities but
right now I would be uh skeptical as
well
you don't have to ascribe malicious
intent to it yet but I would also be
skeptical that the full scope of this is
known one of our sponsors is Helix sleep
I have been sleeping on a helix mattress
at home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a mattress that fits your
needs it ships free you can try it for a
hundred nights to see if you like it and
it comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty
unlike many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you are
supporting good jobs Helix sleep is
giving my audience up to 20 percent off
plus two free pillows what other
mattress company is going to give you
twenty percent off go to helixsleep.com
Pacman the link is down below